[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoy es un día muy especial para mí
justo hoy hace siete años estaba en el
aeropuerto y listo para salir de mi
ciudad y explorar nuevos rumbos en
canadá con mi familia y muchas las
personas que están en esa foto se
encuentra quién las haga y eso me llena
mucho alegría
[Aplausos]
pasamos de 40 grados a menos 20
d
eeuu con nuestra familia a estar en un
nuevo país sin conocer a casi nadie
era casi como comenzar una nueva vida
nos sentíamos a veces solo 61 diferente
pero poco a poco me di cuenta que la
ciudad que nos acogió una ciudad que
adoro mucho en montreal
un tercio de la población es inmigrante
es decir
muchas de esas personas vienen de
nacionalidades distintas
quizás profesan religiones diferentes y
puede ser que sus culturas y sus valores
en diversas pero compartíamos algo
especial que cada experiencia de mi gran
experiencia de seguir de nuestra zona de
confort y tener que afrontar ese tipo de
experiencia de comenzar a crecer y eso
muchas veces nos unió a trabajar en
equipo
en mi caso siempre sigo apasionado por
las matemáticas y la forma que hay para
poder integrarme a la sociedad
quebequense era resolver problemas
porque porque una parte la matemática es
un lenguaje universal y de otra parte
una de las cosas que más me gustan las
matemáticas y que tuve que hacer está
aprender desde muy joven gracias a
estudiantes y profesores que me
enseñaron es el hecho de que en la
resolución de problemas
no siempre la solución es lo más
importante
lo importante es el procedimiento y la
forma como pueden llegar a él
el rol de un matemático como tal está
encontrar cada vez soluciones que sean
más simples más elegantes más eficaces
un mismo problema en el caso de
inmigración y en el caso del
emprendimiento como tal es lo mismo es
tratar de encontrar soluciones a los
problemas de nuestra vida cotidiana y
sino aprender de esos procesos para
volver al problema y tratar de avanzar
de nuevo de una forma mejor
otra cosa que aprendí en montreal fue el
hecho de que la lengua no es siempre una
barrera
los que ustedes ven ahí son los primeros
mejores amigos que tuve en montreal
como ustedes pueden ver son asiáticos
en esos momentos y ellos hablaban
español y francés y yo hablaba mandarín
en ese momento
pero eso
no quitaba el hecho de que pudiéramos
pasar horas y horas contando cuentos
discutiendo viéndonos alrededor de esa
esa pasión que compartíamos que era
resolver problemas de matemáticas
y eso me ayuda a comprender algo muy muy
chévere y el hecho de que
al final todos somos seres humanos y esa
empatía que nos une va mucho más allá de
los rasgos que tenemos o que quizás nos
puedan definir
ese mismo año el año que tomé esa foto
con mis amigos fue que comenzó una
aventura que marcó mi vida
esta aventura de un proyecto de ciencias
se presente en el último año de
secundaria se llamó bolt ese proyecto de
ciencia con la idea que se me ocurrió
con james uno de los amigos que estaba
en la foto
nuestra idea era de utilizar la energía
que producía nuestro cuerpo para cargar
nuestros ayudar porque éste siempre
estaba descargado
digo que comenzó como un proyecto como
una idea como que bueno vamos a ver cómo
funciona se volvió un desafío porque
cuando presentamos a nuestros profesores
ellos dudaron de nosotros
lo primero que nos dijeron es una cifra
no estaba a su máximo nivel así que no
me comprendieron mucho
y dos ellos decían que si una gran
empresa no había sido capaz todavía de
desarrollar ese proyecto es muy posible
que es imposible para como jóvenes de
secundaria iban a ser capaces
eso me puso a pensar también y casi que
desiste
utilicé esa experiencia para explorar
nuevos caminos
y que descubrí descubrí la relevancia de
los vídeos de youtube de los tutoriales
para aprender nuevas cosas cómo soldar
cómo hacer circuito como cómo no
quemarse mientras esos circuitos
aprendí que hay muchas universidades que
ofrecen sus cursos totalmente gratis en
línea así que acceso a la información
no es un problema es es la voluntad que
uno tenga para seguir esos cursos
entonces cuando estaba en secundaria de
5 con mi amigo lo que hacíamos era que
nos sentábamos después de clases y
empezamos a ver vídeos de cursos de my
team
empezamos a explorar empezábamos a hacer
pruebas con los circuitos y seis meses
más tarde
dejamos de apoyar a los profesores de
ese tema pero seis meses más tarde
volvimos al colegio con un prototipo
funcional
ese momento para mí me marcó mucho
porque porque ahí me di cuenta y
aprendió una gran lección que es la que
quiero compartir con ustedes y es que
innovar no tiene etiquetas
no la edad ni el apellido ni
tu educación puede definir lo que puedes
o no puedes hacer
a veces la creatividad y simplemente las
ganas de intentarlo y de estar dispuesto
a aprender esos errores para seguir
avanzando es lo que te puede llevar a
aportar cambios
este proyecto de ciencia
29 evolucionando
y gracias al apoyo y qué pasó
que ya de un proyecto de ciencia tuvo
una idea mucho más global pensé cómo
podemos hacer un impacto nosotros como
ciudadanos
para luchar contra el cambio climático
para ayudar las causas del medioambiente
que dice compartir esa visión con otras
personas que me rodeaban y encontré
muchas personas que estaban interesadas
en colaborar como ustedes pueden ver es
el equipo de volvo hay personas de más
de 10 nacionalidades
desde egipto china españa francia
estados unidos todos unidos por una
visión todos unidos por una meta
fue muy bonito porque juntos logramos
hacer un producto del cual estamos muy
orgullosos se llamaba y uruguay
se trata de un juego que utiliza la
energía solar y el calor humano para
cargar una batería la cual ustedes
pueden utilizar en cualquier situación
en cualquier momento que lo necesiten
esa
todo eso nos permitió de poder viajar
alrededor del mundo representando a
canadá
y al mismo tiempo representando a
jóvenes universitarios y ganar muchos
reconocimientos
pero al mismo tiempo nos permite me
ayudó a entender
qué
esos lazos esas visiones distintas esas
experiencias distintas de todas esas
personas todas que ayudan a que el
proyecto con un valor mucho más
universal y que sea una solución mucho
más apta para distintas situaciones que
quizás no podemos ver nosotros mismos
algo muy chévere es que me di cuenta que
no somos los únicos y de hecho esos
nuevos factores que hace que montreal
sea un líder
casi mundial en varios sectores desde
inteligencia artificial hasta
videojuegos como la aeronáutica a la
ciberseguridad y que haya tantos
emprendimientos el hecho es que estamos
una ciudad multicultural
queríamos decidir hayamos decidido de
unir nuestras diferencias escuchar lo
que vosotros tienen para decir y
colaborar
ha hecho que se quede un ecosistema
mucho más abierto en el cual cada uno de
nosotros cuente
este año decidí ir por una misión poco
más grande
teniendo en cuenta de los problemas que
se están viendo a nivel mundial con
respecto a la crisis de la educación a
la audición que se tiene que dar usando
la tecnología que tenemos disponible
decidí crear un nuevo emprendimiento
un emprendimiento que se llama red life
el objetivo detrás de retirada es poder
facilitar la accesibilidad al
conocimiento
asegurando una transición simple entre
el profesor que da una clase magistral
para proyectarlo en tucson en líneas
pero a diferencia de los cursos y líneas
que ya ya utilizamos y del cual yo
consumo mucho queremos agregar un factor
más el factor humano
hacer de que uno pueda conservar esa
interacción que hay no solo entre
profesor y estudiante sino entre
estudiantes mismos y concentrarnos en
utilizar la tecnología disponible para
atacar un factor muy importante
la personalización de el acceso al
estudio
algo que me dado cuenta con mis
compañeros es que cada uno tiene una
forma distinta de aprender
y muchas veces con ello nos toca
estandarizar
entonces por qué no utilizar la
tecnología que ya tenemos a nuestra
disposición para hacer un cambio un poco
ahí y crear planes de trabajo que se
adapten más a su modo de estudio
para eso el apoyo de profesores de
distintas áreas la universidad de
montreal que me ayudaron a crear un
modelo que sea un poco más
teniendo en cuenta lo que dije al
principio mucho más simple algo que
existe pero que siga siendo eficaz para
poder solucionar ese problema eso que
ustedes ven ahí
para una pequeña es un tablero que
construimos al principio de este año
yo faltaba mucha clase porque tenía que
pedir responsabilidades profesionales
mientras estudian la universidad
entonces sí porque no hago un espacio en
el cual mis profesores puedan dar clases
y yo pueda seguir sus cursos mismos y
estoy afuera del país y no sólo eso sino
poder comunicar con ellos al mismo
tiempo cogemos los pedazos de madera
un pedazo de vidrio y con un taladro y
ciertos materiales arme eso que ustedes
ven ahí
la innovación ustedes pueden ver está el
hecho de poder unir cosas que ya existen
para resolver algo que sigue sigue
siendo existente
el cuento está bien está bien
transparente no es algo nuevo cuento
porque hacer stream vídeos en directo
tampoco es nuevo estamos haciendo ahora
mismo aquí ente de c's
pero el hecho de poder unir todos esos
elementos y poner un chat en vivo en el
cual el profe pueda ver cuáles son las
demanda de los estudiantes de poder
medir las interacciones que cada
estudiante tiene para poder personalizar
su plan de estudios
son cosas que al fin de cuentas existen
pero si no asumen crean algo que puede
ser mucho más útil para la sociedad y es
ahí donde quiero hacer el acento con
respecto a la innovación de hecho que
para innovar no hay que comenzar de cero
hay que ver qué es lo que existe
alrededor de nosotros para unirnos y
crear algo mucho mejor
quiero volver de nuevo a lo que dije al
principio dije que para mí lo más
importante no es la solución
es el procedimiento
porque si bien muchas veces la mayor
parte de veces no vamos a llegar de
forma directa
cada problema que se nos presenta en el
camino puede ser una enseñanza que nos
permita amar un poco más el problema y
que nos haga comenzar de cero e intentar
buscar otra forma de poder atacarlo
es lo que hago muchas veces en
matemáticas para resolver problemas por
eso que estoy tratando de hacer en
emprendimiento
y algo que note que juegan un factor muy
fuerte es la cooperación es el hecho de
poder escuchar personas que piensan
distinto que han vivido experiencias
distintas y que quizás no son como yo
pero como tenemos una misión común
y es por eso el día de hoy no quisiera
ser yo quien termine esta charla me
gustaría que sean ustedes quienes miran
a personas que tiene al lado
piensen en alto para ver cómo podrían
unir el tema de inmigración que es una
crisis que se está viviendo a nivel
mundial y usar la innovación los
recursos que tenemos a nuestro alrededor
para poder brindar una solución que no
sabía mucho más en paz y agradezco que
compartan sus soluciones entonces
barranquilla o que me escriban y con
mucho gusto material
con ustedes